[Arabic recitation]
and first
commands of Islam.
If we were to say what is the first
thing any human being
is commanded by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala?
What is the key to paradise?
When we speak about a key,
a key only works if it has teeth in it.
And those teeth have to match up exactly
with the lock in order for it to
function.
And that key
upon which a person
chisels in and grinds in his or her
teeth to this key. What is it? What is
the foundation upon which all other
actions, all other acts of worship are
built? What is the first thing every
human being is commanded with? What is
the greatest act of worship?
The greatest act of worship is the of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
This is
this is
summed up in the first command
which is the testimony
ofahill.
A person wishes to enter into Islam.
They begin with the testimony
ofahillahillahillahill
that is a proclamation of and an ethos
upon which all other subsequent acts of
worship are built and based.
In a narration,
the companions
Abbas and others
they have mentioned that
the key to paradise
is
the scholars of Islam.
They have mentioned from amongst the
the students of the companions and the
students of the students of the
companions.
They have expounded upon this
statement
of our forefathers, our ancestors, the
companions of the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii Wasam
and they sayahill
is the key to paradise
and all acts of worship
that are based uponahillah
uponed they are the teeth to that key.
So a person in order to begin to shape
his key that will unlock a door that is
specific to him
they begin that
withahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
now they have their key
now they start to grind into this key
their acts of worship of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala prayer
there is a notch in the key zak a notch
in the key. Hajj,
another notch in the key. Jiad, a notch
in the key. Commanding the good,
forbidding the evil, another notch in
the key, etc.
Until on the day of judgment, everyone
has a key.
Everyone who began withahillah,
they have a key.
And this key will open a door
that is
complmentary of this key. If it's a
sophisticated key, a lot of time have
has been taken into shaping it, then a
similar door
will be presented for this person in
paradise.
However, if the key is very primitive,
the person, you know, testified
thatallah,
but they struggled with it a little bit,
they don't have as many notches in their
key, they will enter paradise
as well. However, if a person does not
have a key, all of their deeds, even if
they were for the sake of Allah, even if
they cried, even if they had a heart
filled with love when they
did these acts of worship, there is
nowhere to put these notches that
they've earned.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala says
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala on the day
of judgment
those people that did not begin
withahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
they did not begin with establishing the
key those who had elements of shik
those who did not enter into Islam
starting and ending and revolving around
their of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says and we will
bring forth whatever deeds they did and
we will make these deeds into a
scattered dust. There's nowhere for
these particles. There's nowhere for
these grains of sand to be built on.
This is
what
represents.allah
speaks about the most critical
components of
andahill
is the
the summary the summation of
the religion of every prophet and
messenger.
Hence Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to
our prophet sallall.aii Wasallam.
In the opening verses or the be
beginning verses of
he says
he says subhanahua and we have never
sent a messenger before you
except that we send revelation to him.
We begin revelation to him. We end
revelation to him. All subsequent
revelation to him revolves around and is
founded upon
none is rightfully worshiped but I so
worship me.
And so if we understand this concept, we
understand that tohed is an act of
worship.
The act of purifying beginning with the
purification of the heart
from all other elements of superstition
all other elements of turning to other
than Allah perfecting that
that's the greatest act of worship that
any person can put forth for himself.
Often times when we say what is worship,
what is the definition of worship?
You'll hear answers salah, zak,
fasting of Ramadan, Hajj,
reading the Quran, remembrance of
Allah,
correct? These are all acts of worship.
These are examples of worship and
instances of worship. But this is not
the definition of worship.
And this is why be this is one of the
reasons why we see a chasm
between
people
in the masid and outside of the masid.
in Ramadan and outside of Ramadan. In
Mecca and outside of Mecca, there's a
big difference between who they are in
these two different places or times. Why
is that?
One of the reasons, not the only reason,
but one of those reasons is because
the definition of warship in this
person's mind is extremely
small, extremely limited.
that worship is reading the Quran. It's
making salah. It's so basically things
that only happen in the masid or things
that only happen during a certain time
of year or things that only happen in a
certain place.
And so what happens if this is our
definition?
You will see a person,
they will come to the masid often.
They will be very devout in the masjid
or in Ramadan or in Mecca or Medina etc.
as they should be right but when they
leave these times or places you see a
whole other side of this person that
hasn't been touched or affected by that
worship. You'll see that same kind of
person is a person who lies, who steals,
who cheats others, who harms others, who
uses their tongue to harm other people.
Their Muslim brother is not safe in
their absence or perhaps even in their
presence. Why is this? Because again
that is warship and then the other
compartment of my life is the rest of
the world. And this is very incorrect.
Rather if we were to say what is the
definition of worship? Very simple
definition.
Worship is anything that a person says
or does or believes
or leaves off. Anything that a person
can do to
gain favor with Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, anything that a person does that
Allah loves, this is worship.
The scholars give a more precise
definition. They say
They say worship is a general term in
the Quran and Sunnah
that
includes
all things that a person does or says
whether it's inward or outward that
Allah loves.
What is worship? Anything that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala loves. If you
understand this definition now, you
understand how every single breath you
take,
every beat of your heart, every waking
moment of your life
has the potential to be an act of
worship.
Even if you are asleep,
it has the potential to be an act of
worship. And alkari
the great scholar of the companions. He
said
he said
that he intends
the worship of Allah
in his sleep just as he does in his
waking moments.
Meaning sleep is something that is
neutral. It's not an act of worship in
itself.
Everyone sleeps whether you're Muslim or
non-Muslim.
However, if the person's intention is I
am going to sleep to regain some
strength to worship Allah to use this
strength to use this recharge for the
sake of Allah. Now even your sleep, even
your meal that you eat, even your
customs, they all become an act of
worship. But all of this has to be based
on the main principle of
of
and this is why
the act of worship that is greatest in
Islam
after the pillars of Islam after the
obligations. If we were to say
after all obligations, what is the most
preferred thing to do in your free time?
If you have fulfilled your obligations,
those things which are mustab, those
things which are preferred,
should you spend that time praying extra
or should you spend that time reading
the Quran extra or
that the most preferred and virtuous act
of worship after obligations
is seeking knowledge of the Quran and
Sunnah.
Why? Because you're not physically doing
something per se. However, you are
building that masid,
that temple in your heart
from
which you worship Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
And this is the difference between the
companions and all people who come after
If
a person amongst us were to pray the
best prayer
and a companion of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam pray the exact same
prayer
exact same prayer.
Would their prayer be rewarded with the
same amount as ours?
The answer is no. Their prayer would be
far more rewarding. Why? What's the
difference? It was the exact same thing.
Yes. But what is occurring in the heart
is very different. Very different.
And this is why the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said
[Silence]
inklim
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said
to other companions
because the companions they're not all
the same. There are companions who
became Muslim way later down the road
and there are companions who became
Muslim at the very beginning.
some of the newer companions who had
become Muslim after all most major
events,
they were
having a a bit of an issue with some
of the earlier companions. And so the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said,
"Do not harm my companions." He's
speaking to other companions.
He said, "If any of you were to give the
equivalent of in gold for the sake of
Allah, it would not
be equal to one of those companions
giving a mud or even half of it of
grain. If you put his hand in here
of grain and gave it, the other one gave
the entirety of in gold.
This
handful of grain is more virtuous than
that mountain of gold. Why?
Because of the knowledge and intensity
of what's going on here in the heart.
This is this is the difference. And
that's why you see the companions, the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam, they
didn't go to and make 20.
They didn't go and pray all night long.
No, they did it once or twice, but they
[Arabic recitation]
Allahbar.
Allah.
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us
about the relationship that was shared
between Fyon and his followers.
What was the nature of this
relationship?
Fyon was a very very arrogant man. As a
matter of fact, he is the poster child
for arrogance and rejection of truth.
second only tol himself
when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala opened up
the sea before Musam
and Misam
and Bi is
able to cross that sea
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala delivered
them to safety
We see that Pharaoh
upon seeing this
was only increased in intensity and
arrogance
and he then went right after them.
To us
being removed from the situation,
this seems very illogical. How could a
person see such a thing and still use
his own legs to walk to his own demise?
Yet people do it every single day on
this earth in one way or another.
And when you really read the Quran and
take to heart the details
of what was going on in that husk of a
heart that Pharaoh had,
you can kind of start to understand
the thought process behind him walking
himself to his own destruction.
But the real question is why did
everyone else follow him?
There were people from amongst his
followers
that barely
had anything to do with what was going
on. There were people amongst his
followers who were not as well informed
as Pharaoh and his closest adviserss
were.
people who just kind of jumped on the
bandwagon and did what everyone else was
doing,
yet they were met with the same
destruction.
And so the question is,
what was the relationship between
Pharaoh and his followers?
And how was he able to walk his people
out into such a clear
dead end?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in
describing this relationship
that Pharaoh
did not take his people seriously.
He looked at them as
barely human.
He did not allow them to think for
themselves.
He did not allow them to have an opinion
contrary to his.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in
response to this belittlement, his
people followed him and obeyed him.
It's incredible
that you would disrespect a people and
only earn their loyalty in return. What
kind of people are are these?
When we look into the Quran
and we fast forward from the time of
Pharaoh
to the time of Abu Jah
and his advisors,
Abu Jah, he was referred to as Abu Jah,
which would literally translate to
the person of extreme ignorance.
He was referred to before Islam
as Abu Hecim,
the man of extreme wisdom. And he was he
was a nobility as close to royalty as
anyone could get in that tribal
environment
of pre-Islamic Arab
in the Arab Peninsula.
These were the chieftains.
Abu Jah
Abuahab
ibn Khalifa
Ibn
and on and on.
These were the people that if you or I
were born in Mecca at that time, we
would grow up looking up to these
people.
If you or I were born in Mecca at that
time, if they were in our modern times
as kids, we would grow up with their
posters hanging in our bedrooms.
These were the heroes of society at that
time.
They were the people that every young
man wished to be and every young
woman wished to be with.
When we look at Abu Jah, he was referred
to as Abu Hakim. He was known as a very
fair man, a very generous man.
More than 30 verses of the Quran were
revealed regarding ali.
So much so that prior to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam it was said IF
THERE WERE EVER to be a prophet it would
be
he was extremely generous.
He was so generous that every Hajj
season
when all of these
pil pilgrimmers
came
from all
corners of the Arab Peninsula to make
their Hajj.
He would slaughter from his own personal
wealth. He would slaughter for them 10
camels every single day until the Hajj
season was over and they all left. He
would slaughter hundreds of camels
every single day for these strangers
out of service to the house of Allah.
He had rebuilt an entire part of the Kaa
on his own from his own wealth and the
rest of the Cabba was rebuilt by all of
the tribes of Qur.
He was referred to as Al
or Al
the one who is equal to the entirety of
the rest of Quraysh. Why?
Because every year, just we do to
this day,
we take turns as Muslims
putting the cloak on the Kaa every year.
This is something that they did even
before Islam.
And every year the tribes would all
collaborate and pitch in to make this
cloak.
And every other year he would do it on
his own. This man was doing in the
service of the house of Allah what an
entire city did to take his place.
was not only known to be incredibly
generous but very fair
and a person who had a strong
inclination to justice and service of
his of his tribes.
These men Abu Leah
this man was royalty.
He was referred to as Abu Leah,
meaning the one of akin to burning
embers because his cheeks were so red.
Why is that important? Because the more
pale a person's skin was
and the less tanned a person was in that
easy bake oven desert.
This meant that this this man is of high
status and royalty. He doesn't have to
go out into the sun. He doesn't get a
tan. That's for peasants.
He never had to walk out of the shade
unless he wanted to just for fun.
These are the kinds of men who were the
chieftains of Quraysh.
If you or I were born into that society,
you and I would have grown up looking up
to these people.
There would hardly be a man amongst us
who was not touched by these men's
generosity or fairness in one way or
another coming up in your life or my
life.
But when the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam was appointed and sent as the
messenger of Allah. These men turned
against him
and they started to spread rumors about
him.
They said he was a magician.
They claimed he was a poet. They said he
was a madman.
They claimed he was a liar.
And so on it goes
for 13 long years
to the point that they even all got
together
and made an agreement
that no one and no tribe would have any
dealings with Benny Hashim or Benny
Abdul Mutalib.
No dealings at all. They would not sell
them even a grain of wheat or barley.
They would not marry them.
They would not come to their aid. They
would not sell or buy anything from
them. And they would not allow any other
tribes in the Arab Peninsula to deal
with them. Excommunicated.
And they wrote this down and they hang
this.
They hung this agreement
in the Cabba.
And so three long years of starvation
ensued
in which the bellies of the children of
Benny Hashim and Benny Abdalib
swelled with starvation and
malnourishment.
They would not allow anyone to give them
a loaf of bread to the point that when
people would go to visit their
relatives, they would have to hide
loaves of bread and scraps in their
clothing and in the clothing of their
women just to get something to their
family members or friends.
Now the question here that every one of
us should ask himself
IF THE PROPHET Sam
were to have emerged in today's time
today
what would that have looked like? What
would that propaganda and embargo have
looked like
if he were to have emerged today?
Or if the world was then as it is today,
it would be the equivalent of every news
agency,
every major country
all collaborating
to
defame
and be to defame and disparage the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam and his
companions. If you look at
the men who you grew up looking up to,
the people that you aspired to be like
or even sit in a gathering with them,
they all agree.
Their scholars, their experts, their
nobility, their chieftains, they all
agree
that he is not a prophet. He is not a
messenger.
Look at the kind of people that are
following him. Slaves and children and
women. And look at the kind of people
that are standing with Abu Jah and Abu
and Khalif and Wi,
the nobility, the warriors, the heroes
of the society.
The question here is
if you or I were in that situation,
if we were faced with that dilemma
of choosing which of those sides to be
on
and which of those WAGONS TO JUMP ON,
which one would you have chosen?
It's easy to say, "Of course, I would
have been with the messenger sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam.
But think about it.
Look at what makes you angry today.
Think about the opinions that you have
that you hold.
If I were to say to you, name to me
the BIGGEST VILLAIN OR THE WORST of of
people in the past
150 years in MODERN HISTORY. WHO POPPED
into your mind? Who taught YOU THAT?
MANY OF US to think that our
opinions are our opinions. The opinions
I hold are opinions that I have arrived
at and come to hold through my own
independent thoughts.
But that's not usually the case.
What makes you angry?
WHAT GIVES YOU AND SPARKS YOUR OUTRAGE?
Is it what comes on your phone? Is it
what pops up on the TV?
Do you believe what you're being told
in your phone and on these social media
platforms
and by these news agencies?
Do you swallow the facade entirely?
This is the questions we need to ask
ourselves. Why?
Because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
told us OF MILLIONS OF HUMAN beings just
you and I
who will enter the gates of hell on the
day of judgment saying
we have arrived here because we have
obeyed our chieftains and our leaders.
ers. That's why they are in hell because
they sold their own
and their own soul for someone else's
dunya
and they became a component
in a propaganda machine
and they jumped on whatever bandwagon
was most popular.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us
that when a person is placed into his
grave,
two angels will come and set him up and
ask him, "Who is your Lord?" Meaning,
who did you worship?
Who is your prophet? Meaning, who did
you truly follow and emulate?
And who what is your religion? meaning
what was the ethos and law that you
lived your life by and a person will
answer not with what they know but with
what they did with their lives. These
are where these answers come from.
And so the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam said the believer will say
that my lord is Allah
Islam is my religion and Muhammad is my
prophet Sam
he said
[Silence]
He said, "And as for the hypocrite
or
the person of extreme sinfulness and
disbelief,
he will say when asked these questions,
I DON'T I DON'T KNOW. I heard people
saying something and so I just said what
they said.
These people
jumped on the bandwagon. IT WAS POPULAR
TO be Muslim during their time. They
heard people saying something, so they
said it,
but they didn't believe it.
They didn't investigate it. They didn't
form their own opinion. They didn't use
their faculties.
They didn't reason their way to that.
They just jumped on the bandwagon. They
did what was popular.
AND SO OUR QUESTION today
is, who does your outrage
belong to?
Who
does your opinions belong to?
ARE THEY YOUR opinions
or are they the opinions of our
equivalent of Abu Jah and Abu
and Khalif? Why does Allah tell us these
stories? He documented these stories
meticulously in the Quran so that we
could learn to be vigilant.
It's not that we are to not trust our
scholars or experts. know,
but especially in the environment that
you and I reside in, we have to be very
careful which bandwagon we jump on.
And you can change these things about
yourself immediately.
YOU CAN SWEAR, I will never take my
opinions from an ELECTRONIC DEVICE.
MY OPINIONS, my outrage, my love, my
fear, my hope, it will all come from the
book of Allah and the Sunnah of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. That is
the Muslim.
It will come from the right sources
WITH GREAT CARE TAKEN before I allow any
opinion into my heart.
It is very easy and it is the most
natural thing in the world to just do
what is popular, to say what is popular,
to learn all of the buzzwords.
But as Muslims, we fight a an even more
challenging fight. Because what is even
worse than holding these opinions and
fighting the fight of others that
doesn't belong to us is that we try to
give it an Islamic twist.
Many of us Muslim brothers and sisters
because of the environment we are in,
our children are drinking the poison of
neo feminism, extreme liberalism,
all of these new movements and then
going through the Quran and finding
evidence for these very misguided paths.
It is upon every one of us to
investigate
and to only allow something out of our
mouths that we are certain
will be of service to us when we stand
before Allah in his court.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
is
moment to look down. Make sure that your
feet and your shoulders are in line with
the feet and shoulders of your two
neighbors. Perfecting our rows, not
being out of place in the row,
completing the rows. This is part of the
prayer and this is something that
will determine much of the reward of our
[Arabic recitation]
Bismillah.
in
Allah.
Allahel.
[Silence]
Allahel
Allah Oh,
I can go.
[Silence]
Mama.
Allah
stuffalamikum
[Silence]
brothers and sisters very Quick
reminders. First one is the fud prayer.
Inshallah tomorrow will be at 6:00 a.m.
So tomorrow fud inshallah will be at
6:00 a.m. Also there's a youth program
this evening after I is there's a
bonfire. It's going to be very enjoyable
for the children inshallah. It's going
to be moderated by sister fara and havas
malik. So inshallah please make sure
your children youth is here. It will be
after Isha and there will be Quran
recitation and some reflections
inshallah. So please join and make the
best of it. Also please donate
generously on the way out.
I'm good.
You are electric.